you're really busy because you uh you
were working on four good days and this
is a very
uh this is a completely different tone
obviously
oh yeah how do you get a transition from
this there's no way to transit
there's no way to transition uh that was
it well this is pot and then we get into
a much
heavier substance uh the last topic was
the gateway drug for this topic
but it's it's really a harrowing story
this this movie is a really harrowing
story
uh and it's about it's a true story
addiction true story yeah based on an
article that was written a couple years
ago about a mother daughter
and what i genuinely loved about it was
it's not a
story about drugs and it's not a story
about like why you shouldn't do drugs
it's not
it's just two people's um life set in
the world of four days and they just
have to survive these four days about a
young woman
this all happened an addict goes to
rehab public rehab pays for three days
of
um of detoxing and then the next is up
to you and
there's a shot you can get if you're
sober for four days for seven days you
can get a shot that
prevents you from getting high and so
she just has to stay sober for four days
and the the film is through the lens of
these two and blend clothes myself play
mother daughter and it takes place in
the house and it's just a matter of
worst year won't you that's amazing your
co-stars i mean come on i just like
glenn close like it's no big deal it's a
big deal
i'm totally aware i'm not gonna be an
[ __ ] i was like guys it's no big deal
right
it's a big deal yeah and being in
with her all day long every day was like
genuinely one of the greatest gifts that
i could have had and then pandemic hit
the day after we wrapped i mean it
couldn't have been anymore like
the world is so amazing i'm working with
glenn close the world is ending
everything is shutting down
everybody's like it all was very extreme
feelings we have a we have a clip here
anything you need to tell us about this
i think it's pretty intense i think it's
pretty i mean it's
i think you guys get it like the the
impetus of the film is she goes to rehab
she comes out of rehab she now has to
spend four days with her mom let's look
at this
clip from four good days yeah what drugs
are you using
heroin methadone some crap
uh if i get in and maybe adderall
last time you used yesterday morning
so i'm hurting how long have you been
addicted
10 years more
have you ever been through detox how
many times
14. excuse me 14 times
so
um this is fully based on real
like real events real life and uh and
glenn and i were both really fortunate
to talk to
both the women in in today and like it
isn't every day
it is day to day like there is no it is
a disease right and it's not one of
those right and everything's great and
there's a happy ending and everyone
it's not and this is the real life you
know eyes into it
yeah and i'm quite certain you could
probably talk to anybody
here and in this audience everybody
knows someone who's gone through this at
least somebody or a family member
it's insane how prevalent it is and
tragic yeah
um good for you for doing this thank you
four good days yeah four good days
is available now uh on digital and video
on demand and i'll say this you know
we're gonna pack this up and move on uh
to other things but
uh it is been a real treasure every
single time i talk to you whether it's
on this show or bumping it
into a out in the world you're a real
person
and you're uh genuine and really funny
and lovely and uh just a joy to know you
so mila kunis thank you so much